we've had several crisis crisises I
guess come up the past two years um and
we were debt-free but now we've due to
the unexpected
occurrences um we're now living beyond
our means paycheck to paycheck have no
savings and you know um our emotional
our physical health is taking a toll our
marriage is taking a toll um and we we
want to stop living paycheck to paycheck
how do we get out of this what were the
crises that I had to take a medical
leave and the day I returned to work I
was laid off um and turn we literally
two weeks yeah it was bad so how much
debt are you in now it's
probably I want to say between 22 to
25,000 total and what kind of debt
unsecured loan debt credit card debt um
should I include the car or no yes
that's debt isn't it tack on a total an
additional 60